I'm gonna ask you dr. reyga's are we
gonna be dead are we gonna survive this
thing so I am proud of America right
America has stepped up
we've also shal distance we're in our
houses and we're fighting back this
crazy crazy virus there will be a test
soon to see who has immunity who had the
virus and that'll be key to
understanding what's happening in the
country you'll know if you had the virus
or not and you'll know if you have
antibodies to the virus that's what this
test will show it so you know caught a
post exposure test and it it's gonna
change everything how long will this
take to implement the CDC started doing
it over this last weekend and I think
you'll see it scaled over the next
couple weeks pretty dramatically I was
under the impression that even if you
have antibodies to this thing and let's
say you had it already you can easily
get it again if you have immunity
there's no evidence you can get it again
what I think you're referring to is is
that people who had it and got better
about 30 days later they could still
find some virus on them it doesn't mean
there's live virus it doesn't mean
you're infections it doesn't mean the
virus is causing a problem it means that
there's some remnants of the virus there
are we transmitting to animals and our
animals capable of transmitting back to
us what we know is that cats can carry
this virus that was shown about a couple
weeks ago we don't know if they're
infectious but we know they can catch it
from us and we know they can get
lethargic or lose energy with it Chris
Cuomo says he thinks he can fight the
virus by staying active and not just by
staying in bed and giving up is there
any truth to that or is that a bad way
to look at this thing no question about
it I think the more active you are the
better you're gonna do you don't have to
get sweaty or get your heart rate up
just walking whether it be an apartment
or the backyard is critical to fighting
the virus and keeping your Miria prior
to the virus I'm finding it hard to find
Clorox wipes what can you use in your
house to get this [ __ ] virus out of
my house when you have things brought in
you want to wipe down afterwards soap
and water are just as good as anything
this virus has an envelope around it hey
you know it's enclosing this protein
that's soap degrades like that is it
still okay to take ibuprofen if you get
this or you rather have people take
Tylenol
well the World Health Organization
backed off on their advice to say don't
take ibuprofen and so right now there is
zero data that ibuprofen or any that we
call the nonsteroidals have a negative
I'm walking the other day some guy comes
up behind me jogging and literally he
was two feet away from me when he ran by
and I got really pissed off he should
have moved six to eight feet away from
me shouldn't he have technically yes he
should have and this is the problem
right we're only as good as the weakest
link and so if one jaw gets cocky and
says you know I'm the one moving in a
fast pace and I'm just gonna run through
everybody else we're all in trouble am I
considered elderly we're considering
elderly in this probably around 70 oh
good so I'm not elderly yes now you're
saying that to make me feel better